كَانَ الَّلقْلَقُ يَا أَحْبَابْ
والثَّعْلَبُ أَحْلَى أَصْحَابْ
يَلْتَقِيَانِ بِكُلِّ صَبَاحٍ
بِالوُدِّ وصِدْقِ التِّرْحَابْ
قَالَ الثَّعْلَبُ أَنَا أَدْعُوكْ
يَا لَقْلَقْ لِتَنَاوُلَ وَجْبَةْ
فَلْتَقْبَلْ مِنِّي أَرْجُوكْ
سَنَكُونُ مَعًا أَجْمَلَ صُحْبَةْ
هرعَ الثَّعْلَبُ نَحْوَ البَيْتْ *** نَحْوَ البَيْتْ
لِيُعِدَّ لَهُ أَشْهَى حَسَاءْ *** أَشْهَى حَسَاءْ
بَعْدَ قَلِيلٍ سَمِعَ صَوْتْ *** سَمِعَ صَوْتْ
صَاحِبه الَّلقْلَقْ قَدْ جَاءْ
شَعَرَ الَّلقْلَقُ بِالإِحْرَاجْ
فَالطَّبَقُ مُسَطَّحُ وكَبِيرْ
فلطَبَقٍ أَعْمَقَ يَحْتَاجْ
قَدْ شَعَرَ بِعَدَمِ التَّقْدِيرْ
كَانَ الَّلقْلَقُ يَا أَحْبَابْ
والثَّعْلَبُ أَحْلَى أَصْحَابْ
يَلْتَقِيَانِ بِكُلِّ صَبَاحٍ
بِالوُدِّ وصِدْقِ التِّرْحَابْ
قَالَ الَّلقْلَقْ أَنْتَ صَدِيقْ
أَدْعُوكَ لِبَيْتِي فَأَجِبْنِي
لَمْ يُظْهِرْ لِلثَّعْلَبِ ضِيقْ
بَلْ قَالَ حُضُوُرُكَ يُسْعِدُنِي
بِالمَنْزِلِ طَبَخَ الَّلقْلَقْ *** طَبَخَ الَّلقْلَقْ
لِلضَّيْفِ لِيُظْهِرَ إِعْجَابَهْ *** لِيُظْهِرَ إِعْجَابَهْ
قَدَّمَ لَحْمًا فِي دَوْرَقْ ***  مممم
والثَّعْلَبُ قد سَالَ لُعَابهْ
قَامَ الثَّعْلَبُ كَي يأكل
حشر بعنق الدورق خطمه
حاول حاول و المأكل
لا يمكنه الا شمه
قال الثعلب كيف تحس
هذا مهين أتعذبني
قال اللقلق هذا درس
لم تهتم بما يحرجني
ضحك اللقلق يا ثعلوب
هذا طبق لك ومناسب
تقدير صديقك مطلوب
إنك عندي أقرب صاحب